the key drivers that we're seeing come
on multiple different fronts
on one side you've got the government
policies and regulation like the
european electronic communications code
and the rural digital opportunity fund
in the united states
but also then you've got the investor
appetite from
private equity as well as infrastructure
based funds where they're taking
advantage of favorable policies
and regulations to allow them to invest
safely we've also got the consumer pool
as well which is demanding more and more
capacity
to serve the needs of their work from
home and their ultra high definition
lifestyles that they have today
the biggest obstacles that we see within
the market for adoption of next
generation pond technologies is quite
often just the inertia from those
operators that are already deploying
based on g-palm
chipon's been a great technology for the
last 20 years and it can be hard for
people to move away
but now as we're moving towards true
gigabit societies
that's where next generation pawn will
carry them through the next decade
and beyond
there's no question that operators
attitudes towards gpon are being
influenced by
the european union's new policies with
regard to gigabit service delivery to
every household by 2030.
it's just simply not practical to
believe that a technology that served us
so well for the last 20 years
can continue to service us in in a
backdrop of gigabit society
for the next decade which is the least
that operators expect
from return on investment with new
equipment deployed in the network